guys there's something about this month
my dogs are particularly disruptive
aren't Jeff hello again and here is my
journal for the month of October which
is funny it hasn't been that long since
my September journal it's only because
my September journal was insanely late
so hey it all kind of works out in its
own little way but you're about to see
the adventures of October you're about
to see the things I did things I didn't
do missing days I noticed that like at
first I was like everyday I have to do
an entry now it's like oh three days and
I hadn't done one because you know this
kind of how it goes just living life so
anyhow I hope you enjoy it I hope you
enjoy this month and my dogs are being
really needy right now so I'm just gonna
let you get right into it
yep see look so unimpressed so today is
the 1st of October and it's Joker day
repping the shirt I finally get to see
Joker after everyone else but I'm really
excited this is this is my number one
anticipated movie of the air all I want
is a good character movie for walking
Phoenix bring something special sit it's
all I want go see I don't know why I
like this spot it's next to the
Nespresso machine it just feels like
beginning of the day but ok so I saw
Joker last night I had a night to think
about it all I did was think about it
I've really liked that movie there's a
lot more to say about it so spoiler Tyre
I can't wait for my spoiler video but I
she's like if I'm enough for your
[ __ ]
when you Shakespeare
they hold her head like this and I go to
be or not to be that is the question
totally the wrong song but this came
today so right Ben Riley I love you me
and like ten other people avid fans
don't ever put plastic over your head
you'll suffocate he was taking up a
kingpin mob style pizza just the guy who
got stabbed in the eye by t1000 dancing
next to his twin who stabbed him next to
Christopher Lee count dooku slash
Saruman so todd phillips the director of
joker said that he stopped doing
comedies and did joker because woke
culture has killed comedy which then got
him a lot of backlash from other people
in hollywood i don't know that that
backlash disproves his point
pretty sure it kind of proves it gotta
feel weird today I got to do my Joker
spoiler talk Seahawks Iran so I'm
watching this Seahawks right now but I
woke up with a migraine but it's like
for those of you don't have migraines
but when you get a migraine when one
starts coming on you take excedrin
migraine the pain will go away but this
weird lethargic feeling still sticks
around and so that's what I got but I
still gonna check her spoiler talk so I
hope I'm on my game if I see him off my
game in that video well that's why I had
that headache even when I started
filming my video and by the end is
completely gone which means the
conclusion has to be I'm addicted to
making YouTube videos at least filming
them I don't know it means that is I
just woke up and if I haul ass right now
I can make a showing of Joker go back
from seeing Joker for the second time I
feel like I want to do a video talking
about some of the fan theories on Joker
you know some of the interpretations
because really looking at it there's no
way to disprove
any of the theories I've seen online a
lot of them anyway and it makes
something kind of cooler so I like that
just we're talking about this movie is
pure imagination building up the 4k
collection we got some more real-deal
holy yields predator the Schwarzenegger
one The Shining boning up for dr. sleep
as in brushing up on shining not that
sounded worse than it I meant for it to
Black Hawk Down labyrinth and gremlins
actually I went in there to get gremlins
and the other four were impulse
purchases so the truth I've just really
had a hankering to watch gremlins for
the last couple days cuz you never can
tell there just might be a gremlin in
your house
[Music]
recognises dude it's Mike Ehrmantraut
from Breaking Bad also this baby came in
so I'm gonna listen to that so he's
Joker made a killing in spite of all the
fear-mongering
[ __ ] articles and tweets or maybe
because of I don't know but that whole
thing man that's just that is just what
I just said is fear-mongering it really
is there are a lot of conversations we
could have with Joker all of them not
happening because of the conversation we
were having which is oh is this going to
inspire a mass shooting is this movie
that's not by any stretch of the
imagination the most violent movie
Hollywood's produced lately is this
gonna be the one to cause violence and
like I said my one of my videos I just I
just find it repetitive it's just the
same conversation we've been having
since the 90s which is does art inspire
violence and really what it is is
bloggers and my dogs are making if
they're just wrestling so if you hear
more Taunton sounds that's that's what
it is but really what it is is bloggers
tweeters and legit news outlets chasing
likes and retweets in what I call the
outrage economy because it's very
monetizable the chasing the monetary
value of likes and retweets without rage
articles an outrage posts because mass
shooting might happen because of movie
well that just sounds sexy and that'll
get the traffic that [ __ ] irritates me
but it shows where we are you know it's
all of it for the outraged economy all
right so I got the Ninja Turtles 1up
arcade cabinet I just bought it today
hey gonna have to build it this is
anything I build stresses me out even my
dogs as they bark down stairs I don't
know if your
that built that one though so it's fine
but still we'll see how it goes
this happened with Mortal Kombat as well
that little speck right there is under
the screen so I have to take it apart
again that's back that because that
little thing of dust or whatever is
gonna irritate me so El Camino drops at
midnight so it's 9 o'clock it's 9 p.m.
which is midnight New York time or
Eastern Time so I don't know if they're
doing it at midnight / timezone or
supposed to be midnight Eastern which
would be 9 Pacific or if it's midnight
Pacific I have no idea point is I'm
ready and probably gonna watch it on the
TV down here because I watched Breaking
Bad on TV and I wanted to feel like
breaking bad I don't want to feel like a
movie that feels separate from Breaking
Bad I realize I finished building the
turtles in time cabinet I didn't even
show you my friend and I used to play
this all the time in the arcades when he
comes over I'm going to drop this bomb
on them then we're gonna get nostalgic
this is it right here conflicting audio
sounds of different arcade properties
that is not the song that's that's a
cover band version so I looked into it I
guess it's a very known thing that the
the 1up ninja turtles the original Ninja
Turtles arcade game it doesn't have the
actual the official version of the theme
song I guess they didn't want to pay for
the rights which music rights are like
the number-one cause of things not
coming out you know people never want to
pay for the the music right so it is
what it is it's just the intro but it
does compromise a little bit of that
experience I don't know maybe you can
hack it put the main version on there no
I I'm just gonna blow right past it but
it'd be cool to have it just playing
while I'm doing other things you know
that arcade feel and I'm gonna really
got it for turtles in time anyway so it
is what it is so I got some fine
brothers entertainment which is that
channel that has reactions that people
react to things
people reacting to mine and Stockman's
reviews of Joker dad people reacting to
a lot of Joker stuff but we were the two
reviews on there and I was watching it I
was like this this the one problem with
Joker is that at this point I have more
thoughts about it
it was like that was my first review and
so it's I saw the movie a couple hours
prior and that's me talking about it
when it's fresh on my mind but now it's
been a couple weeks and now I have more
thoughts like oh damn I suppose I could
do another video on Joker I don't want
to I don't want to milk it I want to be
one of those channels it's like oh here
we're still talking about it because
it's monetizable but I do have thoughts
about it and then you have to hold on to
those thoughts I guess until they
announced Joker to if they ever do if
they did a joke or two I would want it
to concentrate on his intellect because
it never actually showed that he's a
genius and the Joker supposed to be a
genius but it never showed that he can't
be you just never had the opportunity to
be so if they ever make a joke or two I
think that they should concentrate on
the fact that oh no now that he's found
himself as a Joker he gets to explore
what he can do and they should show that
he's actually very smart if so when I'm
gaming [ __ ] sits on the couch next to
me and yes those are little dog for his
face you still shed gypsy it's cold
outside now you're not supposed to
I woke up with thoughts because I
watched The Scream movies this past week
I watch em every October so the first
cream is it's a classic but scream has a
couple of moments where I was like
that's still relevant today and screamed
too in Randy's Film Studies class for
film discussion class they're talking to
because someone died at the movie
theater that was showing scream and so
they're having the whole discussion
about do we blame the movies or the
movies to blame for people's actions etc
and I was like wow we're having the same
conversation right now about Joker not
that anything happened in a movie
theater showing Joker because of Joker
was still the conversation is it's still
happening so I found that fascinating
it's been 20 years or still having the
same conversation we'll be having it for
another 20 years but and scream 3
there's a line that says pop culture is
the politics of the 21st century
I think someone quoted Gale weathers Wes
Craven man he knew so hung out with my
friends today and saw Joker for the
third time and the third time still a
charm it's still a great movie
and every time I walk out of Joker I
have more to talk about funny thing is
in my review I said that you're rooting
for Arthur to not turn which is true but
I'm watching it and it doesn't mean you
don't just lean into the fact that he
leans into it doesn't mean you don't
look forward to the Joker being the
Joker I'm one of my friends and I were
talking outside the theater I said you
can root for the caterpillar and the
butterfly and then I was like oh [ __ ] I
should have said that new video like I
was kind of pissed I didn't think of
that phrase because that is Joker like
the simplest way I could put it that
encapsulate the entire movie experience
for that movie you're rooting for the
caterpillar and the butterfly so there's
a VHS of
night trap but I don't want to open it
because you know it's collector I don't
want it to you know like you put a VHS
in the VCR the VCR eats the tape and you
know you're kind of [ __ ]
but of course someone has on YouTube so
that's the way to watch it quite a
nickel every time a girl gave me that
look
shame on you as the greatest ever my mom
is watching Joker like right now she's
in the movie theater watching Joker I'm
curious as to how much you like it or if
she'll like it I told her don't judge me
too harshly when she sees the inner
workings of my favorite character will
say my mom saw Joker she came over and
visited afterwards she liked Joker I
mean granted it's gonna haunt her I
don't know if she said the word like but
we talked about it so much and all the
deeper meanings and the theme of how
society had failed this guy and she
liked Joker Portland retro gaming expo
it's like alright so at the conventions
I usually look for the one or two booths
that have retro game just like that but
everywhere all the time
all right I had this when I was little
and I traded it to somebody for
something else but I'm totally spending
20 bucks to get to the nostalgia back
this is actually it goes into the game
gear becomes a TV and that's how I watch
The Simpsons when I was younger my
parents were like you're not allowed to
it's too mature but I washed it with the
TV tuner on Game Gear all right I'm
looking for a night trap on Sega CD and
I keep hearing about how it's at another
booth and I go where I think that booth
is and they're saying no it's at another
but it's like they're sending me on a
wild goose chase on purpose because
they're like that guy looks like a
douche let's not give it am night trap
but I'm gonna find it for Sega CD so I
can have five versions of the game at
the con you never know what you're gonna
find and I found it after much hunting
for 15 bucks both discs of night trapped
Sega CD the fifth version of the game I
own so I'm happy holy [ __ ] alright so I
you said I look like an action figure
and I just turned this on you know it's
all good do the power do a really good
pose
alright so baby your YouTube channel is
light here look up right here it should
be a purple background of me and my
buddy's face split down the middle so
you don't do anything weird like giving
messages puppies okay cool that's the
key I don't know like is that everybody
what we do we go to conventions all
around the northwest in the greater area
we mess with people in good taste
like like this guy right here great guy
we edited we try our best we try to get
a few laughs in there thanks for me I
just ran into him and they were like hey
we're fans and then I found out that a
YouTube channel is a very important
phone call we gotta go so I'm back from
the Portland retro game convention I
came back earlier on Sunday to make it
to my brother's birthday just you know
more important than retro games just to
the limited run games collector's
edition of night trap for the switch
came to the Sega CD case and so that's
where I'll put my Sega CD discs but
there's two discs but it only seems to
fit one you're the one's gonna be loose
so I don't know if this will hold it in
place
actually seems to be doing a fair job
just smile
so I guess Martin Scorsese said that he
doesn't like MCU movies or they're
they're invading cinema or they're not
real cinema or something like that and I
guess Francis Ford Coppola said
something to point is a lot of people
have you know thoughts on the matter you
know and a lot of people have talked
about it online because I feel like
that's the world we live in right like
whenever there's a line drawn in the
sand whenever there's a gauntlet thrown
there has to be a response it's like
that movie phone booth where it says a
ringing phone just has to be answered
it's like statements like that or the
ringing phone and that I feel like I
don't know if people are gonna agree
with what I say but I just if you just
look at the guy look at his life you
know his legacy is filled both of them
you look at Francis Ford Coppola and
Martin Scorsese and both of these guys I
mean their legacy masters she does
masters of the craft I'm sure there was
a time Martin Scorsese they were like
hey here's a blank check because you're
you and and now the the blank checks are
to the Marvel movies I mean obviously
friend Martin Scorsese and Francis Ford
Coppola both still make films and Martin
Scorsese is still making films the point
is like I'm sure to him yeah it's like
very different it's a very different
world that he's now he has to navigate
and it's probably difficult to do that
if you're in his situation you know no
more blank cheques for him and I'm sure
even if you go back comic book movies
were probably a thing he probably
scoffed at I don't know I'm just taking
a leap here I'm sure he does friends
alike yeah the comic book movies you
know that's why you make real cinema and
now the the tables have flipped the
tables have turned and now it's like oh
no those are the movies that if you sign
out of that that's how you make millions
upon millions of dollars so I mean I'm
sure the joke of they're not real cinema
goes back farther than I mean decades
farther for him then this statement does
definitely just it's like Jared Leto
and the Joker you know like the talk now
is Jared Leto didn't want Joker to be
made but if you look at it from his
perspective he was given the opportunity
to be the most famous comic book villain
of all time the most popular comic book
villain of all time and not only is the
word that they cut a lot of his screen
time from Suicide Squad and then when
that happens he's like ok saving grace I
get my Joker standalone movie know if
they give it to someone else like yeah I
imagine he feels betrayed
like I match if he feels pissed and he
probably feels like that Joker movie
should have been his to some degree so I
mean I imagine his Joker movie and the
Joaquin Phoenix Joker movie Jeff Danger
Danger Danger I'm doing important work
[ __ ] danger stop God I was on a roll to
know Jared Leto is not even in the
conversation of great Joker's out there
you know I'm sure those two Joker movies
were two very different Joker movies but
you know I kind of see how he feels
about it and Martin Scorsese I'm sure
it's very difficult being this legacy
director who was like you know at the
forefront of the conversation of many
years that he was working and now it's a
nose to Marvel franchise and shows very
difficult adjustment for him feeling
your own mortality is one of the more
humbling if not scary things you'll do
in your life everyone will do it at a
point this is probably just him
grappling with that you know you don't
have to agree with everything he's
saying in order to like empathize and at
least feel like I'm at a kind of feel
for you know how I said man I believe
and I've heard a lot of people have the
same sentiment as me it's it's like the
Vita's garnered this cult following but
the PS Vita was a great little system I
mean I've made jokes in the past about
it but in reality its life is a tragedy
and it does
more support than it got Tom and I are
playing Magic the Gathering going
through the old deck the lightbulbs are
not part of it neither are the batteries
but that is impressive look how
organized all that is I mean the
structure the craftsmanship here's
hoping I just got back from terminator
dark fate I do all these franchises
claim they're like alright we're making
it for a new generation we don't need
the previous [ __ ] so we're gonna [ __ ] on
it if not burn it but then be like but
now we'll still have nostalgic moments
in here where it totally looks like we
still need it it's like shooting someone
in the head and being like because I
don't need you but I'm gonna harvest
your organs cuz I might need them
otherwise I'm gonna die it's like you
either need them or you don't you know
holy yeah I'm having a beer I gotta call
my brother
I got a vent just somebody about this
Final Fantasy 10 has aged very well I
don't know why I started recording this
what effort komari died alright I gotta
bring him back to life anyhow good again
so my Terminator dark fates spoiler
video I got this idea to take Kyle Reese
this monologue to Sarah Connor and mess
with it a bit either gonna be awesome or
it's gonna [ __ ] suck but I think it
might be cool till I do it I guess we
won't know so better get on that all
right so I have stopped editing the
Terminator dark fate spoiler video which
is actually coming up very well as a
couple of parts in there yeah I like
flexing a little bit of creativity it
was fun but I'm going to my uncle's
Halloween party and I'm going as William
Shatner unoriginal yeah maybe but I got
the mask for free and I'm really cheap I
said that was the couches recline so
it's a lighter and weird and sad so that
was a month of October thank you very
much for watching it sometimes it's just
me messing around sometimes it's me
gaming sometimes it's me monologuing and
I realized that a point was like wait I
didn't actually film anything about the
Halloween party I went to my uncle's
Halloween party I said hey I'm going to
the Halloween party next thing Here I am
at the end of this video talking about
hey thanks for watching the video
it's just a case of I was there
experiencing the party and a lot of
times when I'm experiencing something
I'm not filming something I'm not
filming it because I'm experiencing it
sometimes you know I remember to film it
like the Oregon retro gaming expo but a
lot of times it's not the case so I just
appreciate that you watch it anyway but
thank you all for watching again and if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more right danger
[Music]